welcome guys this is really nice having
you both on this is terrific hey my wife
was playing up there that I would choose
oh yes that's right your wife Sharon was
on the show yeah no she wasn't
what do you mean playing up with me what
are you talking oh she's getting crazy
with me that's my god yeah yeah she was
very she was very entertaining very
funny but yeah she was out there she'll
talk about anything
yeah you get embarrassed ever Jack when
your mom says I just like a heads up
yeah like you know it's like if you're
gonna come and like jump out of a closet
and scare me yeah I have more fun if I'm
in on the joke right if she's gonna like
bare her breasts on national TV yeah she
don't do that for me yeah we gotta talk
about this Ozzie and Jack's world detour
you guys have a travel show yeah and I
never would have seen this coming
and I was wondering where this
originated and then I realized
Ozzie you have always been a huge
history buff primarily the Second World
War when I was born are you still in
England right wish the plan bomb so it's
not thinking they were play building
that had been bombed right
I grew up in and basically a war site
and so you became very interested in
World War two history 20th century
history and Jack was this a way that you
guys would bond yeah cuz I was never
really into music and dad was never
really into like going outdoors and like
you know doing camping you can still go
outdoors when you're drunk don't come
home for about a week oh you'll go away
for a week yeah that's not good that's
not good so so so so you were more of
the outdoors you want to be outside and
do things so I'll way to kind of like
hang out would like we would watch like
World War 2 documentaries and you know
how we have to work through that and I
would be traumatized by like watching
some like you know god-awful you know
atrocity occurring and I would get
excited over the in Rossum it was a good
bonding experience
you